y
[Música]
las naciones unidas conmemora en su
aniversario 75 con una reunión virtual
que además servirá de apertura para las
sesiones de la asamblea general en una
cumbre donde la pandemia será el tema
central el secretario general antonio
guterres dijo que el virus ha puesto al
descubierto las fragilidades del mundo
tenemos reporte desde nueva york
reunión de cancilleres de la unión
europea en bruselas el bloque no
reconoce los resultados de las
elecciones bielorrusas que dieron la
reelección a alexander lukashenko se
espera la intervención de la opositora
en el exilio este plan ática no busca ya
y la discusión de posibles sanciones
contra el gobierno de minsk tenemos
informe
y la noche de los premios emmy se vivió
de manera virtual en los ángeles la
serie es obsesión él se coronó como
mejor drama senda ya fue premiada como
mejor actriz de drama por euforia y
jeremy strong como mejor actor
watchmen de hb o se alzó como mejor
miniserie y se describe como mejor
comedia
comienza la semana y también las
noticias de france 24 buenos días mi
nombre es ángela gómez los líderes
mundiales de 193 países afiliados a las
naciones unidas se reunirán virtualmente
para conmemorar el 75 aniversario del
organismo con foco en la pandemia el
secretario general de la onu antonio
guterres dijo que la pandemia ha puesto
al descubierto las fragilidades del
mundo y planea decirles a los líderes
hay que necesitan trabajar juntos en los
desafíos globales el consejo de
seguridad de 15 miembros tardó meses en
respaldar un llamado de gutiérrez a un
alto el fuego global para permitir que
los países se concentren en la lucha
contra el kobe 19 sólo se adoptó una
resolución a principios de este mes y
eeuu e israel votaron en contra
vamos a ir a nueva york con nuestra
corresponsal a mamen sala buen día amén
como amanece ustedes este año como toda
la celebración no tiene nada que ver con
los encuentros anteriores la pandemia lo
cambió todo
sin muy buenos días desde lo mayor
efectivamente por primera vez en sus 75
años de historia la asamblea general se
celebrará de manera virtual y ninguno de
esos 90 193 jefes de estado viajarán
aquí a nueva york por las restricciones
de cuarentena impuestas en medio de esta
pandemia las intervenciones serán de
manera virtual con discursos pregrabados
que rondarán los 15 minutos de duración
y solamente un representante por país
estará permitido entrar en la sala en
ese hemiciclo y por supuesto en medio de
fuertes medidas sanitarias como son este
distanciamiento social o el uso
obligatorio de mascarillas una parte
importante que se va a perder este año
son estas reuniones entre mandatarios de
esos esos almuerzos esas cenas que
permiten a los mandatarios de todo el
mundo tratar temas de suma importancia a
la parte buena es que este formato
virtual ha hecho que participen más jefe
de estados que nunca 171 en total este
año como decías el tema central por
supuesto hacer algo y 19 y cómo se va a
trabajar para construir un mundo
postpandemia unificado igualitario
en el que se apueste por preservar el
medio ambiente erradicar la pobreza y
conseguir esa igualdad de género muy
importante también será la constitución
de la vacuna la que guterres ha dicho
que se trata de un bien público y no de
una herramienta electoral bueno en los
discursos arrancan mañana pero hoy se
celebra el aniversario 75 de la asamblea
cuéntenos a qué hora está previsto que
comience
y un 75 cumpleaños que se va a celebrar
de nuevo por esta pandemia en medio de
una austeridad espera se espera que
arranque hoy a las 9 de la mañana con la
intervención en persona del recién
nombrado presidente de la asamblea
general el representante por turquía
volkan voz y seguido del secretario
general de las naciones unidas y por
supuesto la intervención de los
representantes de los estados miembros
de los estados observadores y de la
unión europea se espera que se lleve a
cabo una declaración en la que se
apueste por el multilateralismo en un
momento precisamente en el que el mundo
se encuentra tremendamente polarizado
por esta pandemia gracias no menos
seguiremos conversando esta semana en
otros temas los cancilleres de la unión
europea se reúnen hoy en bruselas el
bloque que no reconoce la reelección de
alexander lukashenko en belarús recibe
hoy a la opositora exiliada este plan
ática no busca ya quien urgió la
aprobación de sanciones el alto
representante para la política exterior
o josep borrell explicó que discutirán
cómo apoyar a la población bielorrusa
lukashenko que lleva 26 años en el poder
como vencedor en los comicios de agosto
y sobre los últimos eventos en la ex
república soviética ya hubo un encuentro
previo de los cancilleres el conti ganó
ayer este domingo en más protestas en
minsk fueron arrestadas 440 personas en
la capital europea está nuestra
corresponsal de esther herrera este es
buen día para usted y sobre bielorrusia
cómo ha ido la reunión entre los
cancilleres con la opositora este plan
ática no busca ya
buenos días ángel hace una escasa media
hora que ha terminado esta reunión con
esta opositora el jefe de la diplomacia
europea yo sepa murray ha asegurado que
son necesarias nuevas elecciones en el
país recordemos la unión europea nos
reconoce el resultado nos reconoce a
lukashenko como presidente de
bielorrusia y por lo tanto pide que lo
importante es que haya un diálogo
nacional y sobre todo que haya paz
y se solucione la situación en el país
aún así aún de momento no hay sanciones
tal y como lleva desde hace un mes la
unión europea intentando aprobar porque
las decisiones sobre diplomacia tienen
que ser por unanimidad y de momento no
se ha conseguido unanimidad para que
haya sanciones en el país han debido a
que ahora mismo chipre bloquea estas
sanciones debido entre otras cuestiones
a la situación con turquía y la
extracción de hidrocarburos ilegal en el
mar de chipre bueno precisamente que
otros temas éste se tratan hoy entre los
cancilleres
pues evidentemente uno de los grandes
temas es estas complicadas relaciones
con turquía la situación en el
mediterráneo oriental preocupa mucho a
los países de la unión europea y van a
tratar esta cuestión de momento tampoco
sobre sanciones van de momento los
cancilleres van a allanar el camino para
que haya posibles sanciones a finales de
semana cuando los jefes de estado y de
gobierno sí que se pueden reunir y
puedan tenerla ustedes la potestad
política para así dar a luz verde aún
así no va a ser fácil las relaciones con
turquía son muy importantes
estratégicamente muy importantes saber
sobre cuestiones de migración para la
unión europea por lo tanto muchas
cautelas a esta cuestión lo que se que
se va a poder aprobar son nuevas
sanciones a empresas que no respetan el
embargo de armas en libia éste haremos
el seguimiento para la reunión de este
jueves y viernes gracias a ustedes en
francia se retoma en parís el juicio
tras los atentados del 2015 prohijadas
rehenes superviviente del tiroteo en la
tienda y perca ser recuerda el horrible
evento que tuvo lugar el 9 de enero de
ese año que le siguió a los atentados
del semanario de charly
recordando los horrores de un día
traumático que quedará grabado para
siempre en su memoria
el 9 de enero de 2015 rudy jada estaba
entre las 20 personas tomadas como
rehenes por américo olivari dentro de un
supermercado kosher parisino
escuchaba una expresión y disparos
quizás hubo dos o tres cuando me di la
vuelta vi a cooley valley disparándole a
todo el mundo llevaba un traje camuflado
y tenía dos ak-47
junto con varios otros
haddad encontró refugio en una cámara
frigorífica en el sótano del
supermercado donde se resguardaron
durante cuatro horas una pesadilla
vivida que jada todavía tiene problemas
para expresar con palabras
todos pensamos que íbamos a morir
alrededor de las cinco de la tarde
policías fuertemente armados irrumpieron
en el supermercado mataron a cooley
valley y liberaron a los rehenes
vinieron a buscarnos con unos 20
policías con máscaras y armas nos
dijeron que no miráramos que cerráramos
los ojos cuando saliéramos de la tienda
[Música]
efe
sirve
dio una zona de guerra sangre por todas
partes no era el mismo lugar
no podemos pasar la página siempre
llevaremos esto con nosotros me dio a mí
mismo como un superviviente
haddad está decidido a contar su
historia de nuevo la próxima vez será
ante el tribunal según dice es una forma
de honrar la memoria de las víctimas
en el marco del día mundial del
alzheimer en france 24 hemos recopilado
varias historias para generar conciencia
sobre esta enfermedad se estima que cada
tres minutos diagnostican a una persona
con alzheimer en francia- veamos
y ya ha estado buscando a su padre
durante los últimos cinco años
el mec y terra tiene alzheimer y hoy
tendría 84 años
mi padre desapareció en el verano de
2015 fue en julio
y él estaba en lo de un amigo y quería
volver a casa
después de eso nunca supimos más de él
deambular es común en las personas
diagnosticadas con alzhéimer una de las
consecuencias menos conocidas de la
enfermedad desorientados pueden perder
la habilidad de regresar a sus casas
para sus familias y sus cuidadores esta
es una carrera contrareloj cosas así
está que hicimos estos carteles de
persona perdida con fotos recientes de
mi padre su descripción y un número de
teléfono para llamar si alguien lo ha
visto aprecio la je
y se reportó la desaparición de su padre
a la policía para que lo buscaran en las
calles sin respuesta recurrió a las
redes sociales y creó una página de
facebook que ahora tiene 35.000
seguidores
gracias a esta página que hemos recibido
muchos mensajes y alertas realmente me
da esperanza sin reclamo
tomar café
françois de 64 años ha tenido que lidiar
con la pérdida de memoria de su esposo
en muchas ocasiones recuerdas haberte
perdido nada te has perdido dos o tres
veces y no sales desde entonces si sos
tres desde entonces françoise se instaló
a su esposo un dispositivo gps en su
celular eso le permite monitorear lo
correcto hama está ligado a mi celular
entonces yo envío un texto con un código
y el gps me envía su localización
donde localización sin embargo en algún
punto del olvidara que tiene alzheimer y
eso es un problema no recordara llevar
el teléfono al teléfono
es un trabajo arduo para sus cuidadores
que suelen estar aislados y sin apoyo
yo no podía salir más así que deje de
hablarles a mis amigos y familiares me
aleje de mi vida social fue duro sé que
yo es gracias a las alertas y avisos que
los pacientes suelen ser encontrados en
la ciudad portuaria de leap un
voluntario de la asociación france
alzhéimer está generando conciencia
entre los comerciantes para identificar
a los pacientes que deambulan
es muy importante que los trabajadores
de las tiendas sepan cómo reaccionar si
alguien viene a hacerles preguntas les
pueden decir estoy perdido ayúdeme
es una situación que un vendedor ya
vivió y alguien que estaba perdido vino
y estaba deambulando sin sentido le
preguntamos cuál era su nombre si tenía
algún papel con sus datos y ella dijo
que no llame a la policía municipal
de acuerdo con la policía los pacientes
con alzheimer representan el 15 por
ciento de las desapariciones en francia
no existe una unidad de búsqueda para
estos casos lo que deja a las familias
sin respuestas y con largas esperas
y los premios emmy se realizaron en los
ángeles sin audiencia por el nuevo
coronavirus hb o tuvo mucho protagonismo
con victorias para sus series como su
obsesión y watchmen sendai a ella era
ministro de quedaron con el
reconocimiento de mejor actuación de
drama la mejor comedia fue cheats creek
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a los pan de mis un programa
de premiación diferente para la noche
más glamorosa de la televisión como
todos los demás la pandemia de
coronavirus obligó a la versión número
72 de los emmy a adaptarse la bienvenida
del anfitrión jimmy kimmel por un
auditorio de estrellas pronto se reveló
como un material de archivo su email no
perdió el tiempo en ponerse político por
supuesto no tenemos audiencia esta noche
este es el lema no mitin de hacer
américa grande otra vez el programa se
hizo eficazmente en la llamada de zoom
más glamorosa del mundo ya que más de
100 estrellas participaron en el vídeo
desde más de 10 países el gran ganador
de la noche fue el drama a superhéroes
de hb o watchmen que obtuvo 11 premios
incluida la mejor serie limitada y
parecía ser la noche de hb o su programa
shocks asientos que cuenta la jugosa
historia de una familia mediática
rebelde fue galardonada con una serie
dramática sobresaliente así como premios
por guión y dirección otro gran ganador
fue el programa canadiense
fue su historia de ganar siete premios
en la categoría de comedia en su sexta y
última temporada se siente como un sueño
del que no quiere despertar no creo que
puedas pedir una mejor conclusión para
una historia esto esta noche con las
elecciones estadounidenses que se
avecinan la política hizo ocasionalmente
irrupción en la ceremonia algunas
estrellas mostraron signos de apoyo al
movimiento black life matter y otras
incitaron a la gente a votar cuando se
celebren las elecciones el 3 de
noviembre
esto es france24
[Música]